it's a cool day in Borrego Springs
California that Eleanor Chimel is
cooking al fresco she's using no
electricity no gas no charcoal or wood
check on this chicken and rice and see
how it's whether it's cooking it's doing
a good job instead Eleanor is harnessing
the Sun to make her meal as she's done
almost daily since the early 80s as long
as there's sunshine regardless of air
temperature solar stoves can be used to
cook everything from meat and fish to
grains and greens while solar stoves can
be a great energy saver in the
developing world they can be a genuine
life saver there is sunshine you have an
alternative to fire and that's important
for two-and-a-half billion people to
learn about because they're running out
of traditional fuels Bob Metcalfe is a
microbiologist and along with the
symbols a founding member of solar
cookers international a small Sacramento
nonprofit their goal was to help stop
the devastating deforestation and he's
the burden of women they have to walk
about two to three miles or so to
collect wood and then they have to tend
the fire it burns their eyes and chokes
their lungs according to the World
Health Organization this indoor
pollution has been linked to the deaths
of almost two million women and children
each year with help from other aid
groups s CI has already trained more
than 30,000 families to cook their
traditional foods with the Sun it's very
much
all amazed that a cardboard box can put
the solar cook it is a simple stove that
only costs about five dollars but will
last almost two years shiny things
direct the sunshine onto a dark pot that
then absorbs the sunshine and changes
that light energy into heat energy and
heat energy doesn't get out of the clear
plastic bag it doesn't get out of the
window solar cooking is also being
touted as a sustainable way to purify
water six thousand people a day are
going to die of waterborne diseases in
developing countries if you heat water
to 65 degrees Celsius 149 Fahrenheit you
can pass your eyes water and make it
safe to drink to determine when this
level has been reached SC I developed a
handy wax based gauge called a huapi if
the water gets hot enough to melt this
whack the water has reached
pasteurization temperatures from Nepal
to Nicaragua there are similar solar
projects underway in nearly every
country worldwide and sei is striving to
get solar stoves into much wider use
[Music]